Gareth Bale a true world-class player
about to lead his country to the World
Cup
the 33 year old is coming to the end of
a career that's seen him win the
Champions League with Real Madrid and
reached the semi-finals of Euro 2016
with Wales
not a bad achievement for a country of 3
million people Gareth Bale started out
on the pitches here a school in Cardiff
that has helped this small country punch
well above its weight on the sporting
stage
which church school has also produced a
National Rugby captain and a Tour de
France winner
not even my father or my grandfather has
seen the whales playing the World Cup so
it's a great opportunity it motivates
the team and stuff quite a lot quite a
lot it's
get that far the last time Wales made
the finals was 1958 in Sweden Cliff
Jones and his teammates went out in the
quarterfinals to Brazil I'm the I'm the
good looking one on the end there thanks
to our world cup debut goal from a 17
year old legend in the making nobody's
heard of Pele I can always remember it
vividly he's picked the ball up in his
own off
and he's gone past three Welsh Defenders
and he smacked the ball and Jack Kells
his manager just to and we thought like
who is this who's this kid nobody had
heard of him I mean that was the
emergence then of possibly the greatest
footballer the world has ever seen was
was Pele
the country's traditional National
Sports Rugby Union has often
overshadowed football in Wales but the
journey to Qatar 2022 has seen the
football team take the spotlight rugby
has always represented what it means to
be well certainly sort of outside of
Wales I think the Welsh football team
have now taken on that mantle the
players are heroes in this country
everybody felt really emotional about
2016 and hearing that Anthem the Welsh
anthem for the first time in a major
tournament but I think going to Qatar
and hearing it against the USA in that
first game that'll be something else
Wales may not need to conjure the spirit
of 1958 when they kick off at alarian
Stadium on November 21st the spirit of
2022 seems to be enough
Polaris Al Jazeera Cardiff